hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in section 3 of
his inquiry concerning human
understanding David Hume sets out
something that is really at the heart of
his entire philosophical project and
that is how our ideas are connected with
each other so he starts out by saying
that there there has to be some sort of
principle of connection between thoughts
or ideas and we might want to consider
before we jump into this what the full
range of what he's talking about there
if you've looked at the earlier parts of
the inquiry you know that he makes a
distinction between impressions and
ideas and impressions are much more
lively many of them are sense
impressions that are impinging upon us
at the moment right so I see the the
light in front of me you hear my voice I
take a sip of coffee and I taste that
somebody pokes me he's gonna use the
example of a wound a little bit later on
and hurts me and I feel the pain or it
could be that I actually feel what he
calls a passion and earlier on he used
the example of being actually angry with
somebody feeling the sensation actually
net sensation but sentiment or feeling
of Ray
so that's impressions and then we have
ideas and ideas are the things that our
mind is stocked with impressions tend to
become ideas as they linger in our
memory or as we call them to mind
through remembering them or through the
imagination and they can be pretty much
anything that we've had before so I look
at the book and I see the yellow of the
cover and the black of the stripe that
says hue minute and the title and
inquiry concerning human understanding I
take my eyes away from it
I can still retain that idea which is a
complex idea composed of a whole bunch
of different things I can still retain
that idea in my mind
and likewise Hume thinks that we have
these experiences impressions if you
like of the passions that we feel and
seeing other people feeling those
passions as well and then we have the
idea of those so ideas cover a vast vast
range it's really anything that the mind
can be considering so then he goes on
and he says it's evident that there's a
principle right and in their appearance
to the memory or imagination ideas
introduce each other with a certain
degree as he says of method and
regularity they're not purely random and
if they were then we wouldn't be able to
have any sort of coherent notion of a
world or experiences over time and this
is not something that Hume himself has
to point out I mean this has been a
commonplace of philosophy since the
ancient times
Aristotle drawing the distinction
between some animals that that have just
sense and then responding in an almost
automatic way by instinct and other
animals that have memory and then can
rely upon it right so this is not
something radically new but humans is
very interested well how does this
actually work how do we arrive at their
being some sort of meth
or irregularity which if we examine our
own you know trains of thought or those
of others in what he calls discourse
that is that talking about things or
writing about things there is a
regularity to it so he says this is not
only in our more serious thinking or
discourse he says it's so observable
that any particular thought which breaks
in upon the regular tract or chain of
ideas is immediately remarked and
rejected so we're having a conversation
with somebody or we're thinking to
ourselves and we're really plotting
something out anything else
popping up we're like that doesn't
belong here get out of here right or we
get distracted by it it starts following
its line as well right so that happens
when we're concentrating when we're
paying attention to what we're doing it
also happens when the mind is wandering
when we're in what he calls reveries
which is daydreaming right he says our
wildest and most wandering reveries even
in our very dreams when we're asleep and
the mind is just doing its its own thing
he says we shall find if we reflect that
the imagination ran not altogether at
adventures but that there was still a
connection upheld among the different
ideas which succeeded each other so not
running at adventures means that it's
not just going after whatever you know
it happens to run across it's not
pursuing things at random there is an
order to it even in our dreams and this
is an interesting observation because
think about how weird and wacky if you
remember your dreams they often can tend
to be right there is a sort of logic
he's saying to our daydreaming and our
sleep dreaming so what is this principle
he goes on and he says we're the loosest
and freest conversation to be
transcribed there would immediately be
observed something which connected it in
all of its transitions or interestingly
where this is wanting the person who
broke
the threat of discourse might still
inform you that there had there had
secretly revolved in his mind a
succession of thought which gradually
led him from the subject of conversation
so when people say random stuff which
you know I have a lot of experience of
people doing that when I'm presenting or
you know putting out videos and people
commenting on them you would say that
there's some sort of principle of
connection that's not immediately
apparent to us but is apparent to them
and which perhaps they could share with
us if they so choose to do so
and then we would see oh yeah yeah I
understand how you got from as we say
point A to point B you know even though
it didn't seem to fit the conversation
so there's always some sort of
connection it makes one other really
really interesting remark here in the
inquiry he tells us that among different
languages even when we cannot suspect
the least connection or communication
it's found that the words expressive of
ideas the most compounded do near do yet
nearly correspond to each other a
certain proof that the simple idea is
comprehended in the compound ones were
bound together by some Universal
principle which he had an equal
influence on all mankind now he's
probably going a bit too far he's
certainly going way beyond the evidence
that he has in the linguistic studies of
his own time but he's on to something if
we weaken his claim a little bit to say
yes there are going to be some you know
ways in which languages do follow along
the same basic you know connections
principles that's what allows us to
translate between languages and to map
onto them of course there's going to be
important differences you know different
ways things are divided up or different
associations that are being made but you
know we can we can sort of abstract from
that at the moment so now we get to the
point where we ask well what are these
principles of Association and now notice
he's gone from talking about a principle
to principles singular to plural and he
tells us I don't find any philosopher
has attempted to enumerate or class all
the principles of Association but this
is a subject worthy of curiosity so he's
saying I'm making a contribution here
what's the contribution Hume thinks that
there's really three fundamental ways in
which the mind associate ideas
and this is a Claire you know
classification that others have later on
taken up from him and applied within
psychology and it doesn't seem to have a
lot of things arguing for it so I do
want to say one other thing before we
jump into that Hume doesn't originate
this in the inquiry concerning human
understanding and in fact comes out of
the book that he drew heavily upon in
order to write that and that is his
treatise of human nature which he wrote
much earlier in his career in which
which didn't do quite well and there in
Section four of book one of the
understanding he talks about the
connection or Association of ideas in
ways that I think is helpful that and
supplementary to what we're going to
look at here so I'll bring in a little
bit of that so he says that there's
three main principles of Association
resemblance contiguity and cause or
effect and notice or not cause and
effect cause or effect and we'll come
back to that in just a moment
resemblance is when two things resemble
each other right and you know that's not
much of a definition he's not trying to
define anything he's saying that there's
some sort of similarity between them in
some sorts of respects it could be that
of structure you know when we say there
could be some sort of other associative
principle it could be that they're the
same color it could be all sorts of ways
but the stronger the the similarity is
the more it's actually like this
paradigm that he has
of a picture leading to a thing pictured
so you know he says that for example a
picture naturally leads our thoughts to
the original and this happens so
unconsciously with us that we don't
often take notice of it sometimes people
have a picture on their desk so they can
remember their loved one or you know the
trip that they took to this place or
maybe they have a selfie on their desk
of them doing something because they're
a little bit narcissistic or they want
to remember that that time in place it's
it's a reminder but it's a reminder of
the thing itself of what it's supposed
to be and if you think about pictures
that we have in our you know social
media and the ways in which we store
images we we do in fact have a lot of
pictures that don't actually resemble
any existing human being think about
cartoons for example but cartoons can
also be understood as you know
resembling somebody in some way all that
kind of looks like this guy this person
resembles Rick Sanchez and resemblance
could be in in other ways as well you
know super smart but also kind of a jerk
and very cynical Rick Sanchez right
if you don't haven't watched Rick and
Morty then you won't get that illusion
but you can easily look it up and then
when you do you can like start applying
it to people that you're connected to
continuity so that's a term that we
don't use an awful lot contiguous is the
adjective that we would more likely use
in the present but it's still kind of a
outmoded word you could think of this as
a connection in space can also be in
time but the examples that that Hume
uses won't have much more to do with
space reality so he gives us an example
thinking about one apartment in a
building he says it naturally leads you
to thinking about the other apartments
in the building or if I think about an
apartment that's
the Milwaukee River you know I think
about that apartment building I think
about the river that it adjoins now you
could also say well wait a second what
if I'm thinking about this apartment and
I'm thinking about another apartment
that isn't connected to it but it's the
same basic floor plan
well that's resemblance that's not
contiguity so you see the difference
between them contiguity means it's
actually like they're together with that
that thing cause or effect why or well
causes are connected with effects and
effects are connected with clauses but
very often the idea that we have is
thinking about one of them and then that
leads us to thinking about the other and
the the order could go backwards or
forwards in terms of causality so it
could be we see the effect and were like
oh man that must have had this sort of
cause and we or we think about a whole
bunch of possible causes for it or we
think about a cause and then we think
about the effect that's going to follow
from it and human in the treatise that
sometimes when we're thinking about
cause and effect we think about the
thing that could be a cause a potential
cause and then we think about the effect
that will follow from it so like when we
get nervous about something great
example in our Cova 19 worried times we
come into contact with somebody like we
get in the elevator and a whole bunch of
people get in and none of them are
wearing masks and they're all brushing
up against you you could think oh crap
all right you know I'm gonna have to go
take a shower and scrub down and I hope
that my mask is actually working what's
going on there you're thinking about
them as disease vectors or potential
carriers and many maybe none of them are
infected right but you're thinking about
them as a potential cause and then
you're thinking about the deleterious
effect that could be had upon you he
talks about a wound the idea of a wound
leads to the idea of pain and you can
think about this when you see somebody
else who is injured and he goes oh that
must hurt now why do you think that that
hurts cause an effect right you see the
and then you think about what happened
to that poor person and you probably
tied in with your own experience and
you're like oh you know I fallen off my
bike like that and scraped myself up
with road rash that really stung are you
drawing on your memory now I will point
out as well that that Hume in talking
about wounds it's one of his favorite
examples for closet effect he also tends
to talk about the sword that you see and
you imagine the sword causing the wound
so in that case the sword is the cause
and the wound is the effect so we can
have all these sorts of chains I didn't
want to bring in just one little thing
from the treatise that I think is
helpful to look at here he says that
it's plain in the in the course of our
thinking that our imagination runs from
any idea to any other that resembles it
and this quality alone is to the fancy a
sufficient bond and Association so
whenever we have ideas that resemble
each other there could be a connection
in the way that our minds work he also
says that it's likewise evidence that as
the senses in changing their objects are
necessitated to change them regularly
and to take them as they lie contiguous
to each other the imagined imagination
must by law and custom acquire the same
method of thinking and run along the
parts of space and time and conceiving
its effects so that tells us a little
bit about how contiguity actually works
we see things that are connected to each
other and we see them in time
you know our senses are moving from one
thing to the next to the next and we
thereby arrive at this notion that this
is connected to this not just by a
resemblance or cause and effect but by
contiguity
we in effect place them into a map that
we retain in our minds so Hume thinks
that these are the main ways in which
our ideas are associated there can be
sort of subdivisions of these but these
are the really general modes of
Association
you